the FAA will order Airlines to inspect
hundreds of jet engines similar to the
one that exploded on that deadly
Southwest flight federal investigators
say the engine blade that broke off and
triggered the accident on flight 1380 on
Tuesday had microscopic cracks 43
year-old Jennifer Reardon died from her
injuries seven passengers were also hurt
and we're learning more about hero pilot
captain Tammy Jo Schultz who guided the
flight to a safe landing Chris Van Cleve
is at Philadelphia International Airport
with new details on the investigation
Chris good morning good morning here is
that Southwest jet they rolled it out of
the hangar early this morning the engine
that blue is on the far side now NTSB
investigators are hoping to wrap up
their infield work today that FAA order
expected to go into effect in the next
two weeks but there are questions now
about just how many 737s may ultimately
need that extra scrutiny federal
investigators are analyzing how one of
the 24 metal fan blades snapped
mid-flight on this Boeing 737 engine how
concerned are you about the safety of
737s in general well we're very
concerned about this particular event
why did this happen as far as trying to
extrapolate that out to the entire fleet
of 737s I think that that's that's
unwarranted at this point passenger
Jennifer Reardon was sitting next to
this window when it was hit by shrapnel
from the engine the NTSB says she was
wearing her seatbelt but was nearly
sucked out of the plane medical
examiners say Reardon suffered blunt
impact trauma to her head neck and torso
that calm voice is Tammy Jo Schultz
moments after the Southwest planes
engine blew pitching the jet 41 degrees
to the left
Schultz and her copilot Darren Elser
steadied the 737 and began a rapid
emergency descent after speaking with
the NTSB the pilots returned home last
night saying we all feel we were simply
doing our jobs our hearts are heavy on
behalf of the entire crew we appreciate
the outpouring of support from the
public and our co-workers as we all
reflect on one family's profound loss
she's very strong
she's determined she's authentic flying
together in the Navy Linda Maloney and
Schultz have been friends for over 25
years
her book military fly mom's partly
highlights Schultz's journey as a pilot
one of the first women to fly a fighter
for the Navy and reaching the rank of
lieutenant commander Schultz grew up
near Holloman Air Force Base in New
Mexico and wanted to be a pilot since
she was little Tammy Jo was the heroine
for that airplane those people they call
her or hero and thank God I really
believe that you know just God had his
hand on her you had her in that place
and she was there for a reason
when the pilots brought this 737 into
land they were coming in very fast about
a hundred and ninety miles an hour
that's 20 to 25 percent faster than you
would ideally want to land a 737 and we
can tell you both the engine maker and
Southwest are assisting with this
investigation
now one member of Congress eleanor
holmes norton is calling for hearings
about aviation safety in part because of
this incident glad Kris Van Cleave thank
you very much